hey what's going on it's bill oh that's
really loud that's really [ __ ] loud
Dale what's going on it's Gober and it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
Monday Monday Monday August 21st mm my
mom I got a hauls mentholyptus you're
not going to want to listen to this are
you you know what I don't have time to
start it over again I just don't you
know one of the weirdest things ever is
when you have to go on a microphone you
got to [ __ ] hauls and your goddamn
mouth and what if we get like how do you
make it go by faster am I supposed to
just spit it out is that what you want
from me all right I will
I don't know way to go here you're just
going to have to hang on a second hang
on a hot cat it's still a podcast as
long as I make noise all right I'm back
I'm back and I got the energy all right
this is the Monday morning podcast fur
it's for [ __ ] August 21st 2017 you
know they aint got no August over there
in the Middle East you know why they
don't believe in Christ you don't
believe in Christ gods like well you
know what and guess what you ain't got
no more August right it's one of so
mantle the time of summer's goes by so
[ __ ] fast that's true man you can
look it up go look it up on the puter
over there [ __ ] I'm going to great
[ __ ] mood I got a bunch of [ __ ] to do
with always as always I'm recording this
court at 5:00 California time on Sunday
you know and I put all this money down
on the Red Sox right you know I've been
betting the Red Sox gambling okay I'm
betting on the Red Sox two of my friends
at Yankee fans right it's on that yep
yeah if you get yet yet yep all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] all rides courts in session
can we hear from the bailiff week
famous judge Jesus [ __ ] Christ
how do pot of people in sports get away
with the [ __ ] puns are just basically
the newspaper industry in general my god
have you reached a verdict yes we have
your honor
that was a homerun you get it they're so
bad this Soph I wish I just wish Sweet
Caroline was his funny bad is all those
Aaron Judge punts if they could just
make it that but as opposed to just
watching a bunch of people who you know
on [ __ ] Black Friday have their face
pressed up against a Walmart window
going duster right how that song became
part of the tradition when the [ __ ] did
that happen when did it happen when will
it go away you know it's bad enough they
sing take me out to the ballgame they
never used to do that in the seventh day
he just stood up and stretched and then
so then Harry Caray did it and it was
great you know why because he believed
it and he was shit-faced and he was
hanging out the [ __ ] window and you
like is that guy going to fall you know
you know those guys who boos their whole
life they get this big round belly and
then they got those little pretzel rods
sticks so when he started getting a lot
of that [ __ ] keg out the window you
know that's why they have that net above
home plate you know what I mean over the
fans it's you know that goes back to it
has nothing to do with foul balls it has
to go to back in the day there was so
many fat alcoholics sticking their head
out you know doing god-knows-what back
then you know I imagine initially they
were just amazed that they weren't on
the second floor of a structure sticking
a head out like you know gee willikers
how the hell this thing stand up people
underneath me but I can't say right then
that gradually morphed into holy [ __ ]
look go far you know ladies and
gentlemen have April here really far
really [ __ ] fire
but morphed into that and then somewhere
in there that was like oh my god is that
a black guy on the field you know they
what they've always been hanging out the
window for years and years and years and
that's why that net was there everybody
thinks it's to protect the fence it's
not to protect the fans back in the day
everybody wore a hat they were fine okay
the ball wasn't juiced-up it was the
dead ball era it go up in the air or you
know those people were tough back then
they built railroads with their [ __ ]
hands you know that's just the Chinese
okay forget about the people that
[ __ ] built the I don't know what the
cotton gin all right I'm off the [ __ ]
rails here I don't want to talk about
all I know is that I'm like all right
I got to get back into baseball you know
what I mean how an old man it's a slow
game and then all of a sudden gets
exciting and then it slows down again
right just like that thing as you get
older every once in a while your heart
does something you're like am I going to
[ __ ] die here okay now I'm good all
right that's what baseball is the rest
of the time it's just [ __ ] sitting
there you know like waiting for a cough
drop to dissolve so you can start your
[ __ ] podcast that's type of [ __ ] so
anyways I decided out of the [ __ ]
blue to Tibet with two of my friends
both Yankee fans right one of the Yankee
and Giants fan the other Yankee and a
patriot fans
figure that one up it's one of those
Connecticut stories right you heard of a
Bronx Tale this is the sequel called
Connecticut story
this guy's a Yankee in a Patriots fan
the most bizarre one of the more bizarre
combinations of fans I've ever seen
[Music]
so I bet a bull you know 50 bucks each a
game so they stand to lose 50 again 50
I'm dropping a c-note of picking it up
on the last two series we've won two out
of three on both of them so freckles
here is up a hundred bucks right is that
right let's see I was down 100 then I
was even then I was up 100 then I was up
200 then I was up 100 now I'm up 200
bucks - what a balloon
right I loved it I almost meant an extra
50 because the guys go donut on you
right now the [ __ ] Aaron judge you
know everybody's going to rise and
courts going to be in session and
they're going to reach a verdict and
they're going to know I get it again
he's going to all run and I was like you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that guy's like old 450 with guys on
base against the Red Sox the last couple
of weekends of course the guys do it's
goddamn Paul Bunyan going up there
swinging the bat then I thought about it
was that guy [ __ ] it I'll bet you but I
was voice texting and I said I'll bet
you 50 bucks he doesn't but it wrote I
bet you fixed 50 bucks he does it and
then I didn't hear back from him and I
was like I you got until you know
midnight tonight to get your bed in or
the offers off the table and then you
said he fell asleep but he's probably
sitting going like what dude I said he
was going to do it why would you I said
he'd do it for 20 bucks then you said
you also think he's going to do it for
50 and I got weirded him out he hasn't
called me all day so that might be the
end of that friendship it's funny how
that happens right 15-year friendship
can end on a voice text that somebody
doesn't understand so anyways the Red
Sox took the [ __ ] series and you know
why they took this series because we
spent 200 million [ __ ] dollars and
goddamnit you know we better be the
[ __ ] Yankees if we could spend that
kind of money I don't know what the yeah
I didn't want the Yankee spent this year
I just don't have most of their own
draft picks so it really doesn't matter
right
or does it I have no idea do you guys
see in Spain they set up 800 checkpoints
to catch that [ __ ] [ __ ] did they
catch the guy I don't know desperate to
ease public fears and neutralize a
terrorist cell responsible for the
deadliest attack in Spain or they would
neutralize the terrorist cell it was
actually gonna I guess going to be way
more deadly but the [ __ ] dopes
accidentally blew themselves up trying
to make a bomb that's the greatest thing
that can happen that's my favorite
terrorist stories when they were
building it and then it [ __ ] blows up
it's such a [ __ ] up world
there's just people on both sides that
are just out of their [ __ ] minds I
don't get it
it's okay why can't you just [ __ ] be
like me and you know battle booze and
watch sports and get excited about
things that don't matter why do you have
to have a [ __ ] cause and get all into
some invisible [ __ ] guy that you
never [ __ ] met and then everybody
around you has to die if they don't
think the way you think what is it
there's a tipping point in religion and
it's a combination of like you believe
too much and you got too much [ __ ] I
don't know what you know I just do a bit
about that you have like too much power
and get too much into [ __ ] religion
like it always goes bad you started
pressing other [ __ ] people you know
like when my people really get into
Jesus white people it gets [ __ ] scary
you know black people get really into
Jesus yeah that's a [ __ ] great
service killer band that's it they're
confined white people it's an open
[ __ ] field whatever [ __ ] they think
they did they did they just they run
with it no checks and balances that's
the problem
so I don't know what goes on with these
five I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about I don't know what goes on
with these people what the [ __ ] you can
spin somebody that they're less [ __ ]
move on the planet is you're going to
walk into a group of people sitting
there watching a show or eating a
[ __ ] slice of pizza and you're going
to kill all of them and then God's going
to be like hey nice going whoo hey buddy
I want to talk to you you know I would
have done that but I could big did thank
God you thought they'd do that I don't
know so anyways so good luck to Spain I
hope you eradicate those [ __ ] right out
of your [ __ ] beautiful country anyway
so why do I talk world politics well I
know why cuz it makes you guys feel
smarter right hey Bill maybe next time
you bring up Spain maybe you could [ __ ]
a girl [ __ ] yourself I'll do what I want
oh by the way I got some I got some I
got a giveaway this week for the first
thousand people
all right now wait a second before you
take out you [ __ ] first the first
thousand people that text a particular
phrase to a particular number will win
some all things comedy merchandise is it
basically stickers all right text it is
that what it is yet I'm just letting you
know that that this is so they can build
up their email [ __ ] database and let
you guys know what's going on with that
site okay so it's [ __ ] transparent
what we're trying to do here for the
price of a sticker that's what we're
trying to do you know we're trying to
get more social media and all that type
of [ __ ] because we got big [ __ ] coming
up on all things comedy relaunched the
website next month Bert Kreischer has a
cooking show on there called something's
burning I'm going to be doing those road
rage [ __ ] videos where you got the
[ __ ] camera on me and all of that
[ __ ] and the person that did whatever
they did Felipe Esparza is going to be
doing a home improvement show basically
your favorite comics doing the [ __ ] that
they like to do being funny we've got a
first ban of special release with Paul
virzi we've got a bunch of stuff going
on and talks of yes all kinds of other
things sports shows and all this type of
stuff so we're trying to kind of let you
guys know what's going on so here's what
you do if you want to stick or if you
don't want to do it don't [ __ ] do it
but you want to do it all you need to do
is text all capitals no space bill burr
B I ll be URR two four four two two two
Reggie Jackson Doug Flutie Derek [ __ ]
[ __ ] that Jerry Remy the REM dog it was
his day today I would have said Derek
Jeter
4422 to two fours three twos
you got it for a sticker and then we'll
be bugging you let you know what's going
on with all these great shows we have
coming up you know we got Bobby Lee we
got our Madrigal we got all these
[ __ ] people all right we have our
reshift smear all right so anyways and I
got to be honest with you uh after these
last six games
red sox-yankees and having money on the
game I got to be honest with you after
all these years saying Petros shouldn't
be in the Hall of Fame the man was right
betting on baseball it makes it better
it does makes it [ __ ] it makes you care
you know you think October baseball is
exciting put your paycheck on a [ __ ]
game in August all right
you don't need Joe Buck and all those
extra [ __ ] microphones to make that
exciting doodle I guess Camaro with tea
sauce am I going to be homeless
you know that's the type that's that's
the type of steaks that you want to race
I'm calling it right now Patriots Giants
the rubber game this year's Super Bowl
Patriots finally [ __ ] win right no
helmet catch no [ __ ] a Brady to
Welker [ __ ] two-foot pass that goes
incomplete no Asante Samuel dropping the
[ __ ] ball none of that [ __ ] we're
finally going to beat those [ __ ] and
you know why Tom Coughlin no Tom
Coughlin is going to be the difference I
love what the Giants are doing I think I
think they're gonna you know and I got
[ __ ] Eli he's got ice [ __ ] water in
his veins
all right their team is looking good all
right and I'm telling you that team's
looking good because I've paid attention
for about eight minutes during this
preseason and I've just been hearing a
lot of chatter about weapons being added
and field goal kickers and all of this
type of [ __ ] and people question in Eli
right as he sits there in his Dockers
and his [ __ ] uh you know I don't know
what he's you know he always looks like
he just did the right thing the way he
dresses right the loafers the [ __ ]
pants the sweater you know just like he
dresses the way I should be dressing at
my age and he's like [ __ ] twelve
years younger than me and the man gets
the [ __ ] job done the later the
season is and forget about in January
the man is lights out okay telling you
telling you it's going to be a rematch
and we're gonna win and I bet that's the
[ __ ] team I want to play that is the
[ __ ] team I want to play cuz we got
nothing to lose they got everything to
lose because I did too we know they can
talk [ __ ] for the rest of [ __ ] time I
want another shot right the [ __ ] - 103
you know I don't give a [ __ ] that
doesn't make any difference if we get
that last one the guy never then we can
give them [ __ ] I you know at the [ __ ]
you know it's not they say imma drop the
[ __ ] ball into the screenplay you
know whatever whatever we got you then
it's been it's over then we got that
thing we can say back that's what I'm
saying you know because I ran to a
couple Giants fans like oh you know why
don't we want it they just logos at this
point Eli is probably the only guy left
from that 2017 and I bet at least I
don't know three-quarters of both teams
are gone since the last one that's why I
never get into those types of stats
going let these guys historically about
the will dividend it's like it's all
different people it's all different
people wearing the same clothes with
better drugs better trucks better drugs
in this system okay just like the drugs
that was sent to a particular
quarterbacks life okay because she hurt
her arm taking cookies out of the oven
okay it was a complete non story however
had that guy taking a queef worst of air
out of the ball all of his rings would
have been questioned that's how it works
okay we're taking callers you know what
I did today you know it was funny I did
so much so many [ __ ] positive things
today so many this podcast is not one of
it but I did so many [ __ ] positive
things today you know and then my wife
my laughs she still had the nerve to be
Moody and I don't know about you guys
but what the [ __ ] oh don't think I don't
know you I don't want to put up with
that I don't put up with the moodiness
okay come on what do I got to do here
what happened [ __ ] thing just died on
me here there we go
I don't put up with that moody [ __ ]
if I did something you got me I'm sorry
all right I said I'm sorry
no that moody [ __ ] find you [ __ ] nine
things right and then the ten things
wrong and then you're going to get all
Moody with me I swear to God I swear
that I just that's it you know what I do
I I go hey hey grumpy what's going on
and if she doesn't [ __ ] snap out of
it then dad I just shut down you know
and then he you know a [ __ ] German
Irish you want to play the silenced game
I can do this all [ __ ] do this
forever all right you think there's a
lot of silence and master of none
let me tell you something right now I
can do [ __ ] silence I don't why I'm
making this motion with my hands that I
grew up with that [ __ ]
rage silence you know days going by hey
you dumb [ __ ] all going to stare at the
Sun tomorrow do yourself a favor just
wait for the pictures you know what I
mean looking at a [ __ ] lunar eclipse
a solar eclipse whatever the [ __ ]
going on here it's a lunar eclipse right
is it the lunar eclipse is the one I
learned that when the earth is between
the Sun and the moon the moon turns red
because it deflects the [ __ ] light or
something the only reason why I know
this is because this shit's happening on
Monday and one of the writers in the
writers room movies [ __ ] and then
there's the other one where the moon
passes in front of the Sun oh my god is
avid avid for thirty seven thirty eight
[ __ ] years did you see that little
not a mean was it a Jif that thing going
around about that newscaster actually we
used to like I used to watch him when I
was a kid and he said that Eclipse said
I was a little iller and there's not
going to be another one in 38 years and
let's hope that when it it [ __ ]
happens on a world that knows nothing
but peace you know and everybody's like
wow wow he said that and then wow it's
just like we've never been at peace ever
ever never will be
they'll never be world taste then ever
we work with Evie the level of violence
that would have to occur for there to be
peace you'd have to be the last person
on earth because if there's another
person if there was just two people at
some point the other person is going to
annoy you and then there goes to peace
right that's what happened with the Adam
and Eve I hate to tell you it all you
people out there that believe we came
from [ __ ] the ocean I actually
believe in creationism whatever the [ __ ]
they call it all right there was two
white people that started all of this
and somehow we had all the other races
out of him he's two white people right
Adam and Eve and they got annoyed with
each other so she goes for a walk right
the snake gets in a rare next thing you
know right she goes over and she bites
an apple which whatever reason is is
healthy it's a good thing it's got fiber
in it you know I don't understand why
the man the invisible guy was upset by
that because you know what it was an
apple with the sugar in it like because
there was no weed a coke a meth or
anything like that like apples where I
guess the heroin it back then and he
said let me tell you too low [ __ ]
something all right you want to live in
this [ __ ] Garden of Eden in will go
yet stay away from the [ __ ] apple
tree that's it
she went down well you know i'ma go
[ __ ] one of those [ __ ] apples in
[ __ ] what's-his-face whatever this is
a brother I don't know what one of that
[ __ ] tease anybody religious listen
to this [ __ ] how to [ __ ] the two white
people ok [ __ ] and create all different
races of people forget about that how if
you just have to two [ __ ] people and
then they bang and then what how do you
keep it going their kids have to [ __ ]
exactly you had nothing didn't you their
kids have to [ __ ] and then their kids
kids [ __ ] is that how we went from Adam
and Eve to [ __ ] cavemen Neanderthals
and those other [ __ ] people with
those sloppy foreheads you know and that
that [ __ ] Frankenstein brow which I
kind of have is that is that what
happened because Adam and Eve bang and
then their kids had to say to sit down
and say children you have to [ __ ] one
another in order to keep this thing
going
right none of it makes sense
none of those stories [ __ ] makes
sense any more than the fat guy and the
red [ __ ] suit going down a goddamn
chimney okay first of all if it was
[ __ ] true all these new homes without
fireplaces would not have a Christmas
what a parents who live in houses
without fireplaces say you know up on
the housetop reindeer pause out jumps
good old Santa Claus looking for chimney
but there isn't one gets back and say
you have no fun go [ __ ] yourself right
no goddamn toys go [ __ ] yourself go to
child world all right that he that's
that's part of his contract you weave
cookies and there's a [ __ ] chimney or
that's it it's over that never dentally
he has no interest in anybody who's not
Christian he makes toys for everybody
unless they're not Christian you know
what it is it's just everyone we were
tribes and we had these tribes and we
just came up with these [ __ ] stories
and as it expanded and everybody started
[ __ ] interact and all the holes in
our [ __ ] you know once you got that
global view that all [ __ ] up all of a
sudden the world wasn't flat you know
depending on what basketball play you
talk to it was round you fall sudden you
find out that it was [ __ ]
around these people aren't Indians
they're not from the [ __ ] enough from
India from America merica right the
greatest [ __ ] oh by the way I forgot to
say you know if you go to tech oh I just
[ __ ] up if you go to text that thing
we're not sending a sticker over seat by
the way this is just for Americans only
and by Americans the Maine United States
of America maybe can and I know you
can't do it because it's a [ __ ]
sticker and then they got to fill out
forms I should have said that earlier
you know I should have done a lot of
things in life but I got to tell you
we're not telling you guys that you know
if you text that [ __ ] number and it's
International the stickers not coming
that's probably one of my biggest
regrets other than the fact the last
time I didn't watch an eclipse you know
there was a guy wishing for World Peace
the next time it came around and now
here we are 38 [ __ ] years later 38
years later are we any closer you know
I'm sure somebody said that in the 1940s
after [ __ ] Hitler and Stalin and all
that [ __ ] a you know there was a last
night there was a typhoon I hope the
next time there's a typhoon it's uh
killing innocent people in a peaceful
world it's never going to happen well
Jesus bill not with that [ __ ]
attitude
the children have to [ __ ] when we return
part 2 with the Adam and Eve story the
story no one wanted to show you alright
so anyways I've been only [ __ ]
minutes into this pile of [ __ ] podcast
that I do in my 25 26 minutes people 26
minutes is some of the most ignorant
[ __ ] you're ever going to listen to yet
you continue to listen you continue to
listen um all right you know what I did
so I get all this productive [ __ ] today
and yes my wife she said pulling the
grumpy thing right like I was going to
wake up this mornin bad - what they'll
do it I was going to go play drums all
right which I'm still going to do but
I'm gonna do it tonight okay but I could
tell she was tired or whatever okay so
the advantage
class that your lady au lait has is when
the kids crying they always have the
option of the boob BAM
instant shut it right puts the kid to
sleep they feel comforted and all that
type of stuff the only way that a man
can compete in that arena is you have to
put the kid in the car and drive around
the block a few times or what I think is
better you just put the kid in the
stroller you just walk around the block
now you're burning some of your dad
bought calories you know your kid gets
to look around and see a bunch of stuff
[ __ ] acid trip birds flying around
jets cars trees right everything is
amazing to him and then eventually they
fall asleep so anyways I could tell my
wife my class was really sleepy so I
said alright you know she goes to be
really nice you can just take it for a
walk because she was up but my wife
wasn't and I was just like all right I
was going to work out of a play drums
you know what [ __ ] I'll do it so I
did went on a nice long walk did the
whole thing we had a great time she
finally fell asleep after like 20
minutes
she finally falls asleep and then I
walked around like extra you know take
an extra long you know walk home and you
know walking further past the house
coming back up come back up you know my
wife's still downstairs I can tell she's
still sleeping we hung out we had
breakfast together right I watched a
little of the Jerry Remy you know Jerry
Remy day at Fenway Park just did all of
that and then she didn't come upstairs
to like [ __ ] I don't know 11:30 11
o'clock or something something like that
then she goes alright let's go out today
we said we're gonna go out oh my god I
let's go out let's go out so she gets
the kid ready and everything but the
[ __ ] shoes I try to put the shoes on
I just can't do it
I can't do it she tries to kick him off
I start laughing and I can't get him on
and I finally got one of them on I
realized I had it on the wrong foot now
like [ __ ] and undo the buckle and I
finally got it on right
and she just kicked it off and I just
laugh it I can't do it I can't do it and
I left she's like really and I said yeah
I go look there's some things you're
better at than I am you just better at
this right so I leave she goes where you
going I said I'm gonna go watch the red
stuff she goes we'll come down here and
watch it so I said okay so then I went
upstairs and she told me how our
tire-pressure was down and I was trying
remember how to do that because I knew I
had the tire-pressure [ __ ] thing you
know expected thing on this you don't
over inflate you don't under inflated
I'm looking up that we got a little
water bubbler we're all out of water
it's a good opportunity to clean the
[ __ ] thing I'm looking at [ __ ] like
that when I'm up there so I didn't go
back downstairs and she came upstairs
[ __ ] pissed at me because she spent
like whatever the next 15 minutes trying
to get ready would my daughter
downstairs which I understand I'm not
spent pan yes but I was up there [ __ ]
yo sis she gets in a mood now she's in a
mood not yelling you know not flipping
out
just in a mood you know they know when
they get the [ __ ] mood I get this
look on this face they stop looking at
you and they make sure that they keep
walking into the room that you're in you
know we should talk to them they barely
say anything back so you know what so
you know what
come on guys let's let's learn something
here so you are aware that she's in a
wat whoa
oh Jesus
somebody's in a mood I'm sorry did i do
ninety nine out of a hundred things
jesus [ __ ] christ
so she's in a [ __ ] mood then I got to
go out you know because I got my
fucked-up driveway I got to get my car
the way bring her [ __ ] car out
because you got to get the [ __ ] air
and the tires
oh and I'm out though you think I'm
mutter I put on a clinic of muttering
huh talking to kid up the goddamn
[ __ ] Hill come down make a buck of
[ __ ] about that dick and clean out two
water bubble and I got a camo friend
right Henry Hill so that's it I think
I'm doing all right I will match your
mood with
and even dumber moot so that's it so
then she starts to sense that I'm in a
[ __ ] mood now her mood put me in a
[ __ ] mood now she's sensing that I'm
in this [ __ ] mood so now all of a
sudden what does she do she starts
flipping it around being nice right and
I'm just giving her [ __ ] quick
answers like Jerry Lewis rest his soul
passed away today Dick Gregory a few
days ago and now Jerry Lewis Jerry Lewis
arguably one of the funniest human
beings that ever lived ever lived he
actually spoke at my college graduation
and he was phenomenal he did the
parent/student breakfast and when he did
that he was crazy Jerry and then when he
spoke in my college he was coming down
the aisle he was still crazy you know
they bring people and yet it didn't no
[ __ ] the the [ __ ] with a Dean and
all those people come down with their we
have a special colored castle you know
we're higher than you you know they come
down in their robes well he was coming
down and he put his hands on the
shoulder of the person in front of him
here when those dumb hats on to when he
put his hands and when he walked down
was just going wow kicked out of
everyone's dying laughing but when he
went to give the speech he was telethon
Jerry it was great you got to see the
full gamut of the guy absolutely love
that guy that guy made me laugh like
nobody's business so very sad day and
Dick Gregory I learned about him
obviously being a comedian a long time
ago read that book calluses on my soul
all those stories about him being one of
the first black guys to ever work like
white rooms you know the Playboy Mansion
in Chicago playing that because
what's-his-face they accuse cool enough
to let him play this so rest in peace to
both of them so anyway so notice all
pales in comparison of those two comedy
giants all right so I matched my wife's
mood with my mood all right so now she's
not done all cocaine now she's trying to
be nice to get me out of my [ __ ] mood
because then she realizes this is all
silent by the way this is all body
jerk little answers one of these things
now she realizes that oh I took my mood
too far I over Lee made my point which
justified him now being in his [ __ ]
mood right so then at some point she
finally just goes hey I just gonna like
she goes are you gonna be in a bad mood
for the rest of the day I'm like I'm not
in a bad mood I'm in a great mood we
have an awesome house I tell jokes for a
living
we're gonna go gonna go out today I'm in
a good mood I have the day off I am in a
good mood you on the other hand I don't
know she goes I'm over I'm over I go
fine tonight he's gonna like you know
not talk to me I said look we're going
out shopping for kids shoes the second I
see kid shoes it just puts me in a good
mood that if they [ __ ] adorable
little Jordans the little shell toes if
the kids clothes are the cutest [ __ ]
things ever they're not even for kids
they're for adults see some little sport
call you I go yeah you can't help it so
I told her I said just let me get to the
[ __ ] kid's sneakers and then that'll
put me in a better [ __ ] mood do you
know what I saw today it's some [ __ ]
over on La Brea they got this they got
this store it's just all these crazy
signs and all of this basically junk
just [ __ ] from businesses that shut down
or a remodel this guy just has all these
[ __ ] sad so I'm walking up and they
actually had the old school the little
McDonald's arch with the arrow that said
drive-thru open 24 hours that's what put
me in a good mood all that all the
childhood memories we were a McDonald's
family we were not a Burger King family
I was a big thing back then you know
nobody talked politics she didn't talk
[ __ ] religion okay you talked about
sports and what do you like that Coca
Pepsi Coke or Pepsi McDonald's of Burger
King
those were the big [ __ ] debates
pected
and I was over with McDonald's [ __ ]
family we used to go to this McDonald's
I don't even know where the [ __ ] it was
like in Peabody or North Redding way
back in the early 70s it was off it was
near these railroad tracks and I
remember there was these [ __ ]
seagulls and pigeons and [ __ ] and you'd
be eating outside and then throwing them
french fries and then you got to see a
train go by and it was the cool this is
like pre I'd pads pretty [ __ ] you
know Internet there was nothing to do
cartoons we are our UHF antenna was
busted I could only watch cartoons on
Saturday so this was a big [ __ ] deal
I'd always get a cheeseburger small fry
in a chocolate shake that's what the
[ __ ] I had you know for a long [ __ ]
time past when it wasn't filling me up
you know but you were afraid of your dad
it's like I'm not going to ask for a
quarter pounder with cheese I don't know
I don't know what this is going to do to
the whole dynamic everybody's in a good
mood I'm not I'm not going to try to
[ __ ] go up a size here
that's how Americans got fat once dad
became dads became their kids friends
they weren't afraid to [ __ ] supersize
their meals the last four years of
ordering a cheeseburger small fry and
chocolate Frank
shake I was still up [ __ ] starving at
the end of it eyeballing my younger
brothers cheeseburger like he gonna
[ __ ] finish that oh you little [ __ ]
gummy bear in a [ __ ] teeth I'll eat
it
so anyways I saw that thing today and I
was just like I would [ __ ] I don't
I'm not into junk I'm not into stuff but
there's something about that thing I
just think it's [ __ ] cool to get it
fixed up as the [ __ ] base was all
bent and [ __ ] but to fix that [ __ ]
thing up like I just I was i sticked at
the end of my driveway
had that thing live my class like you
know you know neighbors would hate it's
like I know this I would never stick it
out there if I had like you know find
some giant [ __ ] house right you know
and there was some sort of I don't know
what you know those [ __ ] houses those
those Republicans have them you know I'm
not saying there's not rich liberals but
the Republicans live in those states
where you can [ __ ] have a house and
then another house on your property you
know have an old barn you know you just
let your wife your wife gets the [ __ ]
house then tell us-- my [ __ ] dream my
dream right you know but I mean I would
love to I came about the interracial
couple I can't go out there into [ __ ]
Nazi land you know all these [ __ ]
people marching around but anyways I
would love to have a [ __ ] old house
in one of those states that still has
clean air that if it even exists and you
just got a giant [ __ ] butt used to be
a barn and on the bottom you'd have your
daily driver your classic car and like a
[ __ ] sick motorcycle all right and
then up top I'd have it [ __ ] closed
if he had I always told you this be a
drum room [ __ ] place to work out and
the rest of it is just a [ __ ] cigar
bar you know and did some stupid [ __ ]
reason I would find a place for that
McDonald's drive-through side you know
but the more my wife hated it the more
it would drive me into the barn anyway
so let's read some advertising here for
this week shall we
I always hit at Burger King try to a
clap burgers a flame-broiled yeah and
then frozen and driven in a [ __ ]
truck across the country you know you
still ways show that in the commercial
like this sitting there with some
[ __ ] open grill back there cooking
these [ __ ] things and I cooking these
things he wrote me on these biondi's
Burger King or Mickey D's dough two to
two million bees
beyond easy to both if you please become
a fat [ __ ] and yes stomachs hanging over
your tiny [ __ ] Whitey's where's his
nuts wouldn't it be nice if they were
cradled in a nice piece of [ __ ]
velvet me undies everybody do you want
to look good in your underwear and be
comfortable well Julia but that right
balance is hard to find don't sacrifice
style or comfort checkout me undies
common and find the best pair of
underwear in the world talk about why me
undies is the best underwear you will
ever own feel free to improvise I I
don't [ __ ] know you know why because
you don't have to go out to the mall
they just deliver them right to you you
feel special right you order enough of
them you can kind of heat them all
together and you got a giant soft pillow
and your head gets the feel with your
nut still right the big head gets to
feel with the little head feels how was
that me undies will be the most
comfortable pair of underwear you will
own made from a sustainably sourced
naturally thought fabric that is
evidently three times softer than cotton
Jesus know that as fight Marg right
there
ultimate feel-good undies for when you
want to feel naked but not be naked so
the fellas the undies diamond scene
pouch cradles for your cradle for your
jewels like a terrazzo nutsack
you know I sang that last week or my
mother-in-law was upstairs and gives
Laney and gives you stuff sorry gives
you stuff the support it needs without
feeling too tight and ladies will love
the soft eco-friendly fabric so soft and
so touchable covers it up but lets it
breathe ladies right now me undies has
an exclusive offer for just my listeners
get 20% off your first pair and free
shipping and me undies is so sure you
will love the underwear they even offer
100% satisfaction guarantee you you
order a pair if you don't love your
first pair get a full refund this is a
no-brainer
20% off free shipping on 100%
satisfaction guarantee what are you
waiting for it to get 20% off free
shipping and their 100% satisfaction
guaranteed and get the best and soft
decided where you will aro go to me
under Starcom / birth that's me on the
comm / bird this is a limited time offer
so what are you waiting for
start wearing the best underwear of your
life it changed my life time to let me
understand yours go to me honey calm /
Berg
right now all right
Dollar Shave Club dote Dollar Shave Club
Dollar Shave Club is this mod a choice
you'll get a great shave at a great
price conveniently delivered right to
your door you no longer have to schlep
to the [ __ ] store to buy a cheap
disposable razor that gave you a cheap
shave or spend a fortune on a razor with
gimmicky shaving technology yet al
[ __ ] need right now when you use
Dollar Shave club's executive razor with
dead dr. CAV easy the blade will giant
just glide gently gently glides giving
you a smooth shape dr. Carver shave
butter it's transparent for a more
precise shape helps prevent ingrown
hairs and fights razor bumps in other
words works on white people's faces and
black people's faces make the smarter
choice by joining Dollar Shave Club to
date for a limited time new members can
get their first month for free of the
executive razor with a tube of dr.
kathie shave butter for only 5 dollars
with free shipping
after that razors are just a few bucks a
month that's a $15 value point 5 bucks
there's no hidden fees no commitments
cancel anytime you like you can only get
this offer exclusively at Dollar Shave
Club calm / / that is
dollarshaveclub.com / / oh look who's
here
it's our old friends old zip
are you hiring what are you do you know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates talk about the challenges of
finding great talented and/or the
importance of finding great talented to
a successful business well I'll tell you
I've got to tell you you know when
you're looking for somebody you got to
make sure you get the right person with
all those people out there that have
[ __ ] morons it would really be great
if there was a way if the world is well
treated [ __ ] they collect different
cruder how zip recruiter is different
with zip recruiter you can post your job
to 100-plus job sites with just one
click then they're powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else that's
why zip recruiter is different unlike
other job sites Syd arrow doesn't depend
on candidates finding you it finds them
in fact over 80% of jobs posted on zip
get a qualified candidate in 24 hours no
juggling emails are called - you're also
simply screen rate and manage candidates
all in one place with zip
easy-to-use dashboard right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip not
really good I'm running out of ways to
do it for free that's right free just go
to zip recruiter comm / / that sipping
Cruiser comm / / one more time hey try
it for free go to zip recruit calm / /
production host production notes hosts
are not to mention any competitors
including why would you say all of these
[ __ ] places I almost read that how is
it record of an advertising would be
this long and they don't really have
stupid is you [ __ ] you never saw
anchorman god damn it who put that
question mark there that's me oh if it's
there I will read it stamps calm
everybody
stamps calm saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
I can mail any letter any package using
just my computer printer in the mail man
comes and picks it up avoid the hassle
of post office and mail
for postcards two envelopes two packages
domestic or international create your
stamps account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long-term
commitments click print mail shoot [ __ ]
and you're done
unlike the post office stamps calm never
closes not man they got to go better
than that unlike that [ __ ] down the
street like the [ __ ] legs down the
street stamps calm never closes oh wait
a minute that would mean a hurry she
closes I don't like that proved down the
street I [ __ ] it I marry print postage
for letters or packages at your own
convenience 24/7 keywords descriptors
descriptions I'm supposed to say
convenient easy reliable flexible just
like a [ __ ] right right down the street
she's easy she's reliable always wants
to [ __ ] and God knows she's flexible
call-to-action all right I use stamps
calm because why because every once
awhile Excel [ __ ] posters after my
show I go out and meet the crowd and
goddammit I don't wanna go to post
office okay and if my assistant can
figure out how to [ __ ] use stamps
calm the goddammit so can you and right
now you two can enjoy the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps calm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bur that stamps
comm enter burst and stock never go to
the post office again you know I'm one
race behind with the MotoGP my I really
[ __ ] enjoy that and I actually I
think I like it better than Formula One
because there's all kinds of passing
there's no passing in Formula one it
seems after you know as far as the first
guy that's my big complaint and another
guy and all this amazing racing in
position four and five and six well
[ __ ] show that anyways let me let me
just plow ahead here me undies every no
no I already did that I mean let me ask
no read the questions for this week this
is what
to be doing all right okay boyfriend's
Facebook all this is never good all
right
hi Bill straight to the point me and my
boyfriend we've been together for two
years
now and we're happy smiley face the
thing that concerns me is that a few
times on his facebook Messenger I saw
that he is writing on a weekly basis
with an ex college colleague of his a
beautiful young lady the thing is that
they were close at work back then but he
quit three months ago and I just don't
believe in male-female friendships I'm
talking from experience also when we
were want basically if I you know if
we're having a conversation we're talk
and eventually we're going to [ __ ] is
what you say also when we're watching
some videos and stuff on his on his
phone in the search field I saw a list
of a few girls names other than that he
has been great to me and hasn't shown
any signs of a man-whore yet am I too
suspicious or do I have the right to
worry thanks and go [ __ ] yourself I
don't [ __ ] that's not enough that's not
enough information uh I wouldn't you
know this ex-colleague that's a
beautiful lady yeah that's weird
that's your right that's [ __ ] weird I
don't know about the [ __ ] phone [ __ ]
that's uh I have no idea
I have no idea what that's about but
that that thing there yeah that's
definitely a red flag you know I mean
like well put yourself in his position
if you were [ __ ] you know close with
some guy and you left the job three
months ago and you still chat on
Facebook and you know here's the thing
about women that they can sit there be
like oh I thought we were just friends
they seem to be able to get away with
that but I would always say to the woman
I was with us like listen can I tell you
something that guy wants to [ __ ] you
okay I don't care how much you have in
common and how you both like [ __ ]
rose' or whatever the [ __ ] it is
and he really listens to you when you
talk he wants to [ __ ] you yeah so I
don't know what you do there because you
went on his Facebook and you're snooping
so that's one of the things you know if
you're gonna pull that moment you better
be
right because if you're not then they
get to play the you know how dare you
snoop you know how dare you [ __ ]
snoop on me it's just like I mean don't
women have the out why are you snooping
on me because you have a dick sir that's
why I trust you I don't trust your dick
alright missed opportunity I've I would
bring it up I don't know if you bring it
I don't have enough information that was
a really quick and to the point which I
really appreciate but watching some
videos and stuff to the search field I
saw a list of a few girls names that's
not good either I don't [ __ ] know but
I don't know who the girls are but that
there right there that that [ __ ]
ex-colleague thing I don't know I don't
know that seems like a [ __ ] in the
future to me that's what I if I was
standing in front of a green screen
little meteor all just to be a [ __ ]
you know dick floating towards a woman
with their mouths open down stuff
alright missed opportunity hey Billy
buckaroo I'm going back to school soon
within the next week actually I got an
offer a couple days ago to register for
a class this upcoming semester that is
essentially a paid internship in it
entailed working with a company called
Sun corporation why is my stomach
growling because I'm going to diet
called Sun corporation on a software
project if you complete the internship
you get paid a couple hundred dollars
like two or three hundred and of course
something worth putting on your resume
for job hunting but the thing is that I
turned it down I didn't think it would
mean that much to take it as I don't
really need the money and software
engineering majors are for the most part
guarantee a job after graduation plus I
only have one semester left and it's
looking like it's going to be pretty too
and it's locally it's going to be pretty
tough anyway alright so you get a
concentrate in schools what's the
problem he says however I cannot help
feel a bit pissed off of myself for
saying no it's one of those things that
has virtually no negatives to it I get
to I get work experience and money what
more could I need anyway I can't help
but see this as a wasted opportunity
my question to you is a government
offered an opportunity in your committee
career that you've pissed out pussied
out on and then heavily regret it later
and can you offer me advice on this
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself alright
first of all dude it's a [ __ ]
internship it's your last semester it's
going to be tough you know you want to
[ __ ] go out and party a little bit
it's not the worst thing it's not the
end of the [ __ ] world and absolutely
I had oh my god all kinds of times I
pussied out early in my career I was
afraid I was afraid to go onstage I was
afraid of bombing I was afraid of the
whole [ __ ] thing so yeah there was a
whole bunch of times that I did so what
I would do I started to do in moments
like that my [ __ ] stomach will start
I got eat dinner I was good today for
lunch I had lentil soup and a [ __ ]
salad and you know I've just been
driving trying I'm laying off the booze
I don't even [ __ ] sweets
you know writers when we have [ __ ] at
Friday's and when we just order whatever
we want and [ __ ] they got barbecue
and I just you know that's like at my
age that's that's like nap food it's
really like drinking like [ __ ] nyquil
of some [ __ ] so I can't do that
anyways let's see how about our dads
sorry I just click this [ __ ] down
look at the button yeah how would I
answer this I would basically say what I
did was I I always remember what it felt
like when I [ __ ] doubt that night when
I put my head down on the pillow my big
Charlie Brown [ __ ] hand I put it down
on the pillow and I just would always
remember like that awful feeling of
pussying out you know and then I so then
the next time that moment happened I'd
be like alright tonight whether I kill
whether I bomb whether I just - okay I'm
gonna feel way better than if I didn't
even try so but I think you're being too
hard on yourself on this one I mean you
didn't [ __ ] out you just said no seemed
like you weighed your options if you
were too afraid to do it then I would
say that you [ __ ] that but I don't
think you did but
if your reasons for doing it were
different you know if there was some
sort of fear involved you got to figure
out why you did it and then you got to
forgive yourself for doing it because
it's part of like you know you got to
fail to succeed right remember that
Michael Jordan commercial you know
missed all those shots uh-huh missed all
those shot they failed over and over and
over and over and over again that is why
I succeed there you go same [ __ ]
thing
same [ __ ] thing alright nose job dear
Billy mozzarella legs
why hello Jay my daughter yelling at me
in there she does this hilarious thing
when you're on the phone you have a nun
speaker she sees you talking into and
she just says going back what do you
yell it about you know I was telling
that story of how you know I did all
that stuff II this morning and you got
into a mood so then I matched your mood
without my mood then we had that little
game that you play with in you try to be
nice to get me out of my mood you know
that little thing no I don't know what
you're talking about
Mia I don't know what you're talking
about
Mia what do you want me to say know what
I'm saying I don't know what he's
talking about either Mia what what what
that's funny game or you know you're
going to mood and then then and then it
puts me in a mood then you go okay maybe
I took my mood too far so now I'll be
the one to turn it around and then you
know me you always got to [ __ ] pull
me out of the anger mud right fine yeah
oh yeah can you tell guys you hear in a
voice I look how beautiful you are
hey bloody how you like the computer
anything with the screen on it you like
what are you yelling for because you got
to ask my DNA is that what the problem
is
you realize as you grow up every time
you screw up I'm going to get blamed for
that because I'm the screw-up in this
relationship that's right
talk to the people
tell the people what you're feeling huh
what do you got there what are your
feelings about global warming what
should we do nothing the baby senator
was surprisingly quiet on some of the
biggest issues out there hey how're you
liking you loving the Aqaba kados aren't
you the mushed-up avocados you liking
them
sheesh I just you have Mike right sure
know what it is surprised you didn't
grab it alright here we go
i someone's going to ask a question
about a nose job some reason my [ __ ]
whoops sorry too many cursing my stomach
is growling yeah alright nose job dear
Billy mozzarella less white like the
mozzarella I'm a 43 year old married
father of two yeah you like that huh
very happy with my life but could use
some advice you see I have a schnoz oh
my god do this your nose is still
bugging you 43 you married a woman loves
you you got a couple of kids a real
honker a really big nose they'll tell ya
I got a big nose over here now you want
to talk I've been able to get by with
the successful life career and marriage
but in the back of my mind okay the back
of my mind and whenever I look in the
mirror I just can't get over my nose I
kind of look like old old joke Groucho
Marx all those old joke Groucho Marx
with the glasses without glasses now my
question is why are you yelling why you
I gave you the floor and you didn't want
to talk and now you're yelling there
cutie what are you doing huh where you
say there wrinkles my little sharp eh
all right where am I now my question is
being that I've come this far in life
and at my age do you think it's super
vain or silly
get surgery done money money your wife
is not an issue I just think it's silly
of me to really want to do this but it's
really affecting me where I don't want
to look at myself in the mirror when I
shave or put on contacts thanks to the
advice and go Yankees okay guess what
New York no no New York oh yeah great
the greatest promo ever Wheel of Fortune
if you can ever find it
when they went to New York I get away
New York huh
that was it second clip here's a thing -
I I actually don't get surgery yeah you
got to learn to love yourself but here's
the thing when you got a friggin giant
nose it's really defines your face like
people that's what you look like and
when you shave that thing down you've
not you're not going to look like
yourself anymore and people going to be
like you know I bet I bet you're what's
wrong with you I bet if I talk quieter I
bet that the only person that really has
issue with your nose of you you know
your wife loves you your kids love you
you got friends you find I wouldn't do
it I would do okay you think you think
that I haven't looked in - you know
whatever Michael Jackson had bleached
out of him - put a little bit of that in
me so I can work wear shorts can I have
some of that leftover pigment look B
always gonna have something bite
something you don't like I am a firm
believer and just keeping yourself in
shape yelling over a baby and and
basically you know aging naturally you
look way better all right whoever makes
us knows what they're doing
however if you're going to go that route
road I don't know I don't know you
better make sure you find somebody good
in fact because you can end up like that
that chick from dirty dancing what I
thought was gorgeous and I love their
nose yeah I love you know she looks
beautiful
yeah she died no I
she looks she looks so cute she got the
lead in the movie with that nose Barbra
Streisand who else has a very strong
nose Sarah Jessica Parker what who are
the guys I have like strong new Joe
bartnik jobar Joe Clark Nick yeah knows
that lady that lady when she made fun of
his nose and he said you need to lose
above 40 pounds before you talk to me
[ __ ] one of the great lines ever and
that her husband turned around when she
complained looked a joke to one look at
Joe and then started yelling at me
like you [ __ ] oh sorry I'm not gonna
lie that's what I would have done I
would have picked a smaller guy why what
are you saying
please think you st. pay attention to me
man Martha Saskia you talk to me anytime
you all right ask girlfriend's dad for
hand in marriage and he denied no whoa
whoa okay we got two reasons whoa baby
daddy quiet okay
this once is riveting you got to listen
to this one kiddo
all right hi sir I sir William burr hey
lon you know so funny is the amount of
people they're going to say mean stuff I
get it she's cute but I swear to God if
you bring a kid on that buggy and looked
at all right long time fan thank you for
all the laughs she got me through some
hard times and I am thankful to all
right well thank you very much anyways
I've been dating my current girlfriend
for five years come this November I'm 25
and she is 24 I've been thinking about
proposing so I decided to do an old
tradition by asking her father's hand in
marriage now that's a that's a classy
move the dads like that stuff I also
asked her mother to be sure to be there
as she is very close to both of them I
took them out to dinner and I told him
how much I loved her and how much she
means to me etc etc once I was done
giving my speech they just stared at me
like I had three heads they didn't give
me their blessing to marry their baby
and went on saying that they don't think
that I get along with her
oh that they don't think that I get
along with their siblings well and it
seemed awkward when we the family are
together
oh my god they said that they felt like
I would try to move their daughter away
from her family because of my job and
she belongs with her family Oh No should
I keep dating hoping that something
changes or that the relationship with
their parents can't be repaired or
should just give up on this 5-year
relationship any help would be greatly
appreciated Thanks
I fall that sucks yes and I can tell you
this right now marrying into that I know
that effin nightmare that's going to be
a night yeah you better love this girl
because I'll tell you it buddy huh yeah
that that sounds like those parents are
going to screw up do they live on a
compound that sounds like the Rayburn's
in bloodline or something you're trying
to marry into one of those families yeah
I would walk it you've got to talk to
his girlfriend about it and be like
listen I wanted this to be a surprise
but I went out and I asked your parents
about getting married I wanted to do it
the right way and this is what they told
me and see what she says like and I
think you just kind of go from there
but yeah those Freemasons or something
you know you marry into the family too
so if you don't get along with them on
that level and they're already looking
at you like man this sounds like some
blue blood yeah Don you know the hedges
never need clipping her away is she the
youngest is she like what I'm just I'm
curious as to did you not see this
coming whatsoever because I would find
that a little hard to believe but maybe
he hadn't spend much time with him well
if he didn't see it coming
that would mean that he's a dope and
maybe that's why they don't want to
marry the kid this guy's got no
anticipation skills he doesn't see
what's what's the hand in front of his
face like obviously you know that you
don't get along with the siblings I feel
like that probably wasn't a surprise to
you it sounds like nobody in the family
likes you but that woman so she's going
to have to then make a decision you or
them which is very romantic for somebody
in their 20s but eventually as you start
having kids and stuff Christmases and
all that Oregon
dude I I don't know how much you love
her but this would be a great thing to
walk away from if you could that's five
years it's a long no no he's 25 it's a
five years 25 it's the first three years
they should have been a relationship you
got to be a free agent College huh you
got to get the lay of the land out there
I'm a no pun intended over this yeah
maybe they think you're just too young
or one no they said why they don't
approve so I think you if you're really
you got to talk to your girl about it
they don't like them uh yeah you gotta
talk to your girl and see what she says
do a favor just dump Brooke so then she
doesn't know why and then she won't
blame her family's it because you're not
going to marry into that I I would leave
I I would leave right now okay we're
moving on to the next question I would
leave no you wouldn't you've got to talk
to her about it all my 20s I wouldn't
have because I would have been smart
enough but in my 40s if your family was
just like yeah you know we just don't
like it dude and I would just be like I
yeah I agree with that but he has to
talk to her about it he got you guys
taught you got to tell her what happened
can you get the little crazy person here
crawling all over me she just dropped it
she just dropped him it's right it's
right here she's going for the computer
lanyard so it's really there you go
buddy here you go okay Kimmy all right
let's look at the lesson girlfriends
sociopathic mother
Enya can you give me can you give a
woman because women never write in to
this podcast cause I'm such an [ __ ]
can you give some quick advice here this
woman went on Facebook she's been with
this guy for two years she says they're
happy he does everything right
everything's fine but she checked his
Facebook why
because you guys stare happy and
everything is going okay why did you
check to see how much my check was for
today huh oh my god I can't believe
you're just putting me out on Front
Street like that because you guys snoop
it's what you do anyways I was just
curious
see now you're going to have everybody
with the gold-digging WH o re comment
that's not why you did it is because we
did a job together
and you wanted to see what I made versus
yeah job package for their families and
job back use for the family yeah you
wanted to see how much I made first what
you made obviously I know you're going
to make way more than I make okay
I was just happened to be there I mean
they did request me but that's a whole
other story
anyway boyfriend's Facebook straight to
the point my way let's go back to the
check there why I was I like watching
you twist in the awkwardness that I live
in day to day so anyway she goes to
check the facebook Messenger and she
said I saw that he is writing on a
weekly basis with an ex colleague of his
a beautiful young lady the thing is that
they were close at work back then but he
quit three months ago mm-hmm okay
keep going that's it and what I just
don't believe in male-female friendships
I'm talking from experience
bat bat bat man what do you say what do
you say what's the question what are you
doing go back all good when we're
watching some videos on his phone and a
search I saw a list of a few girls names
other than that he's great to me yeah
listen this is why you don't go snooping
in social media and phones because if
you find that you because the thing is
if you are looking in that direction
you're looking for something so any
little thing no matter how innocent is
going to get you off what's up in the
head so if you're going to go looking
for stuff you're going to go find stuff
so either drop it or confess that you've
been a little Snoopy snoop and you're
paranoid and you're insecure but I think
you should just zip it and move on and
not look at his his social media or his
phone anymore Wow I said she should
actually ask him about that
that guy but you're the lady I would
listen to the lady here well I said
either one you got to like fess up and
be like listen I've been feeling kind of
insecure lately and I went in your
Facebook and I saw that you messenger
somebody and first of all I apologize
for invading your privacy because I
wouldn't appreciate it if you did that
to me but second of all but since I've
done it lets that both who is this [ __ ]
that's alright
girlfriends sociopathically mug but you
know you're wrong for looking in the
Facebook and you know you're looking
wrong for looking in the phone you're
wrong you're wrong for that so just know
that girlfriends sociopathic mother hey
Billy bull I can't say that for another
I know but still not sure if this is the
right place for mm questions but I'm in
dire need of redheaded see no wisdom so
I've been dating this lady for about a
year now and her mother is a next-level
piece of crap
there are countless examples her site
psychopath II of her psyche open up but
there are countless examples her
psychopathy even they would leave out
words I already read bad enough but to
trim the fat on the store story I'll
just I'll cite a couple of scenarios
she has repeatedly asked me whether I
use protection whilst banging her
daughter and when I've responded yes she
goes on to say she has no evidence that
I do use protection what would there be
evidence where would there be evidence
no effin clue once your bang in her
house and she's checking the wastepaper
basket they don't want her daughter to
get pregnant I am 21 years old and she
is called my mother on multiple
occasions to ask to meet up with her and
my girlfriend dad to talk about my
girlfriend and I my mother's obviously
declined the invitation and she has
continued to get she's continued
continued to persist other than that she
is the helicopter parent of the century
and calls my girlfriend at least 15
times a day to tell her how to live her
life I hate this woman with a burning
passion but I don't know what to do
about it with my girlfriend my
girlfriend is trying to set boundaries
with the mother but it has had no luck
we just don't answer the phone I think
about the future and I never want to see
this woman again let alone have her be
in the law being in law or the
grandparent to my children I'd love to
hear what you think thanks and go after
yourself yeah I mean this see where this
guy's thinking at 21 that other guy
should have been thinking at 25 but
you're going to marry into that so I
mean you're young enough where you know
ah your girlfriends only a few years out
of the house but she needs to just don't
answer the phone yeah she just doesn't
she's worried her daughter's too young
and is going to like leave her forever
and all that stuff she's like attached
he's like I don't think she's a
sociopath
yeah who's kidding who neither one of us
know this woman neither one of us know
this woman we don't have enough
information but we're going on we have
to go off of what people write to us
that's the only way that we can we have
to let go all in it's like when you
watch a TV show you're just going to
watch it you can't be like well that
would never happen is that of event you
just feel like this isn't dr. Phil des
I'm not pretending to like solve some of
these problems within 22 mil you need to
stop punching her in the face and stop
doing math okay when we return
[Laughter]
yeah you got a toss of your girl you're
obviously your girlfriend knows but yeah
you just gotta ignore the mother yeah
just ignore but ya know peace if she did
worse if she's calling like 15 times a
day and she's asking about that sex life
and she's calling their parents that's
really that's crossing the line
yeah you got to respect your kids
boundaries like their own personal space
you can't be calling somebody's
boyfriend asking them if they're using
protection ask your daughter if she's on
the pill and if she's not get her some
otherwise what are you calling me for a
lady yeah that's weird Jesus gets you
paws out of my pants a lady exactly all
right that is the podcast for this week
congratulations to me but winning all
this money on the red sock Sox making
baseball exciting by gambling there's
your lesson you are so adorable all you
do is smile a happy baby yeah been a
good mood all day look at you she's
getting mobile everybody and they think
since she sees she wants to get her
hands on then she gets her hands on and
then she wants to go to something else
and I'm gonna tell you something right
now
nobody can flip over faster than this
one by the way shout out to Ric Flair
hope he's doing better
I heard that he's recovering and I'm
looking forward to seeing him doing the
flare chop the flare strut the flare
flop all of it absolute legend we
already lost one of the funniest guys of
all time and Jerry Lewis yep
Dick Gregory do you realize how many
stories went with those two guys just
today and forget about Don Rickles that
just closes a porthole to like Sinatra
the whole Rat Pack Redd Foxx Richard
Pryor all of us that porthole just
closed so I hope somebody made a
documentary all right that's the podcast
everybody oh I tell you what my dad
saved today on the couch she was a bar
eating a faceplant right off and I'm
just like like lightning quick Mia
lightning quick like a freckled pasty
Cobra I was able to grab her all right
that said she started she's going for
the the mixer here all right you guys I
will I'll check in on you in Thursday
said it nice because the kids here all
right
see now right